>>> WE HAVE NEW REPORTING FROM
TKPHRP COLLABORATION WITH THE
GLOBAL HEALTH REPORTING CENTER
ABOUT A TEXAS DRIVER DRIVEN BY
KEEP PERSONAL CONNECTION,
TRAVELING ALL THE WAY HERE TO
UKRAINE TO HELP LOCAL DOCTORS
TREAT THE WOUNDED OF WAR, BOTH
SOLDIERS AND CIVILIANS.
OUR DR. SANJAY GUPTA JOINS US
NOW WITH A REMARKABLE STORY.
>> Reporter: HEY, JIM.
YEAH.
WE HAVE SEEN THE MISERY OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN UKRAINE.
2,000 CIVILIANS NOW KILLED AND
MANY MORE WOUNDED.
EVERY TIME WE SEE THE AMBASSADOR
AND EXPLOSIONS ON TELEVISION,
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE RUSHING
IN TO TRY TO HELP THE INJURED,
TRY TO SAVE THEIR LIVES, AT RISK
TO THEIR OWN LOVES.
THIS DOCTOR IS ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE, AND HERE IS A LITTLE BIT
OF HIS STORY.
>> WHENEVER I TRAVEL TO THE WAR
ZONES AND I LEAVE MY HOME,
ALWAYS I DO ONE-WAY TICKET.
>> Reporter: THE DOCTOR IS
GETTING READY FOR A JOURNEY HE'S
MADE BEFORE.
HIS THIRD TRIP FROM HIS HOME IN
EDINBURGH, TEXAS, TO EASTERN
UKRAINE.
.
>> AS A PHYSICIAN FIRST, IT'S
OUR DUTY AND OUR ETHICS TO HELP
EVERY NEEDED PERSON IN THE
WORLD.
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT FEELING.
I'VE BEEN IN WAR ZONES AND
DISASTER ZONES AS A REPORTER.
HE AND I WERE IN HAITI AT THE
SAME TIME IN 2010.
AT TIMES, I HAVE FELT COMPELLED
TO HELP.
HOW MUCH DO YOU WORRY NOW ABOUT
YOUR OWN SAFETY?
.
>> EVERY TIME I GO BACK, I SAY
THIS IS MAYBE THE LAST TIME I'LL
BE GOING.
WHEN I DECIDE TO COME, IT'S A
LOT OF FEAR.
AND THEN IN A MINUTE I JUST
REMEMBER MY PROMISE AND PEOPLE
LOST THEIR LIVES AND THEIR
CHILDREN NOT SEEING THEM.
>> Reporter: A SYRIAN-AMERICAN
RAN OVER 30 MEDICAL MISSIONS TO
HELP HIS HOMELAND DURING THE
CATASTROPHIC WAR THERE.
EVEN AS THE CONFLICT CONTINUES
IN SYRIA, HE FINDS HIMSELF IN A
SIMILAR SITUATION IN ANOTHER
COUNTRY
>> WHAT IS HAPPENING IN UKRAINE
HAPPENED IN SYRIA.
AND I FEEL MYSELF I AM PART OF
THAT.
.
>> NEARLY TWO MONTHS OF WAR, AT
LEAST 119 ATTACKS ON CLINICS AND
HOSPITALS HAVE LEFT THE
UKRAINIAN HEALTH SYSTEM IN
DISARRAY.
AND DESPERATELY IN NEED OF
OUTSIDE HELP.
>> THE HOSPITALS, WHICH HAVE
BEEN ATTACKED BY THE RUSSIAN
ARMY.
>> Reporter: DR. JAZJI SPENDS
THE NEXT FIVE DAYS IN A CONSTANT
BLUR OF ACTION.
IS THERE NOT ENOUGH CARE TO BE
GIVEN?
.
>> A LOT OF HIGH-COMPLEXITY
SURGEONS.
TRAUMA.
LIKE WE DID A SURGERY FOR A
PERSON WHO LOST HALF OF THEIR
UPPER MONTHS TEAR OROF HER
SHOULDER, CHEST.
THIS MAN SURVIVED.
>> THERE ARE ISSUES WITH WATER,
ELECTRICITY, SHORTAGES OF
MEDICAL SUPPLIES.
PERFORMING AS MANY AS HALF A
DOZEN IN A DAY,
ONE THING HE LEARNED IN SYRIA,
IS THE NEED TO PERFORM SKIN
GRAFTS AS SOON AS POSSIBLE TO
REDUCE THE RISK OF INFECTION.
>> THIS IS THE MOST CHALLENGING
REALLY KIND OF SURGERY BECAUSE
THE MORE THE FASTER YOU COVER
THE BONE, YOU FACILITATE HEALING
AND PREVENT INFECTION.
>> Reporter: THESE ARE PATIENTS
WHO HAVE BEEN INJURED IN THESE
EXPLOSIONS WE HAVE BEEN
WITNESSING ON TELEVISION.
THEY MAY LOSE SKIN, THEY MAY
HAVE FRACTURED BONES, THEY MAY
NEED AMPUTATIONS AND YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT CREATING FLAPS TO
TRY AND TRY TO CARE FOR THEM, IS
THAT RIGHT?
>> YOU MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE IN
PEOPLE'S LIFE.
>> Reporter: DR. YAZJI DOESN'T
JUST PROVIDE MEDICAL SUPPORT,
THOUGH, HE PROVIDES A FORM OF
MENTAL NOURISHMENT TO THE
UKRAINIAN DOCTORS AS WELL.
>> WHEN I SEE UKRAINIAN DOCTOR
SUFFERING, BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
EXHAUSTED, MENTALLY, PHYSICALLY,
AND THE ATTACK ON THEM, I SEE
US, WE ARE THERE, THAT IS WHY
THIS IS ALL MAKE ME COME TO
UKRAINE AND BE WITH THEM.
>> Reporter: THE MORNING AFTER
OUR CALL, HE STARTED FOR HOME.
BUT LEAVING WITH A PROMISE THAT
HE WILL BE BACK.
>> GOT TO TELL YOU, JIM, SO, YOU
KNOW, HE STARTED DOING THESE
MEDICAL MISSIONS IN SYRIA, BACK
IN 2011.
DONE 30 OF THEM SINCE THEN
PEOPLE ARE ASKING ME, AS WE HAVE
BEEN REPORTING THIS PIECE, HOW
LONG DID THAT CONFLICT LAST.
AS YOU WELL KNOW, JIM, IT GOES
ON.
THAT'S ONE OF THE POINTS
DR. YAZJI WANTED ME TO MAKE,
SOMETIMES THERE IS A LOT OF
ATTENTION ON THINGS AT THE TIM